[Applause]
thanks I'm going to move over tuna I
said the hot seat is going right on the
bottom of it starting out for a moment
people get takes a moment for people
usually to get used to someone's voice
especially probably mine tonight is you
might hear that I have a little bit of
an allergy going or something and I was
just talking a couple people in the
front row and saying I was taking
something like robitussin a few weeks
ago for this which has been around for a
while when it came a be woozy when I was
teaching in the college classroom they
said well there's probably a lot of it's
probably a lot of alcohol in that and I
said well I didn't really know and I
guess I'm not used to drinking in the
morning but that gave me a thought and I
thought I'd just start out the night
talking about my book Nazi terror as I
really haven't drunk much in the morning
in my recollection the only time I
remember drinking in the morning is when
I was doing interviews with some people
who were perpetrators of the Holocaust
and for example I remember a man who I
talked about at the end of my book the
very end of it who at the time was 88
years old and living in Cologne in the
short and he was and I'm pretty tall
person and so he seemed very small but I
would guess he was about 5 foot 5 he was
the member of the hey told me he had
been a member of the SS not only that he
had been a guard at Dachau concentration
he had been a guarded said I don't know
which one I'm supposed to thoughtfully
this one more is what they said he had
been a guy had been a guard at Dachau
concentration camp and he had been a
policeman in a small town called Ava's
ville they're not too far from Berlin
and he had also participated in shooting
Jews on the Eastern Front from time to
time as he was called up to fight
partisans and while they were sitting in
his living room in a very simple place
an old person's home now in the city of
Cologne I was looking around the room
and noticing how there was lots mementos
of this whole of life and pictures of
his wife and family but his wife was
apparently dead she certainly wasn't
there she made less sad impression in a
way it was very very hospitable and
offering alcohol and so I drank red wine
out of a crystal glass with him not
knowing what else to do and and then he
put him on and told me about how he had
waited in the blood up to his middle of
his calves administering mercy shots
after he and five others had killed
about 300 people he said on one
afternoon my revolvers it seems like
every time tonight talked with people
like him I didn't talk with too many
people like him but a few they always
seemed to offer alcohol and as I hear
they often drank alcohol before they
went on and carried out there are
murders activities in the field sort of
a grim beginning but people get used to
my voice and I started to get used to
where I am anyway my story is a story
about Nazi terror the title of my book
and what I tried to do in this book was
I think four major things and what I
like to do the first night is to tell
you a little bit about the
background of my study what the major
questions I was trying to confront what
kind of evidence I used and trying to
confront those questions that I would
have a second part where I'll talk a
little bit about one part of it talk
about some people who really intrigued
me who I call local Eichmann's those are
people who were the heads of the Jewish
desk of the Gestapo in individual German
cities and I mentioned in particular two
of them who I studied in great detail
man named Carl Brewer from Cologne and a
man named Richard schulenburg from the
city of Craig felt neither of these
people are known to anybody really but I
found them intriguing and I think
understanding their backgrounds their
motivations tells us something I think
important about the who was culpable for
them committing the Holocaust in Nazi
crimes in general and finally I would
summarize some of my major findings
which were dealing with things outside
of these local Eichmann's as I say this
is one part of my study one important
one and then when I'll focus on here
tonight and I'll read a little bit to
give people a flavor of that book when I
get there but as everybody hear me fine
now we all were all fine now with with
that no still not he's still my problem
is I'm not sure which mic he wants me to
speak in this mic is bigger this way Jim
is this so is this okay for the people
in the back okay this is the problem
okay I'll try to speak in this one this
is when people hear from actually and
then people filming this or want me to
talk in this one hopefully hopefully it
works down okay yes okay the four major
questions which I confronted in this
book on the following one what was Nazi
terror bike at the everyday level in
Nazi Germany was the Gestapo which was
the prime organisation of the terror
was this a kind of war well Ian's
organization that had a presence that
was so terrifying that all Germans
irrespective of their background were
constantly afraid that they would be
soothed away and taken to Gestapo
headquarters and then sent off the
concentration camp or was it something
else secondly what was the role of every
of ordinary Germans in perpetrating Nazi
crimes and also possibly in resisting
out of Hitler in the Third Reich
how much resistance was there on their
part of significant was this how
significant was their role in
perpetrating these crimes these would be
the role of the more obvious organs of
the terror like the Gestapo then what
about this Gestapo
what were those people who work for the
Gestapo what kind of people were collar
fur of Cologne and richard xuan book of
Krefeld
and the other officers of the craze of
the Gestapo and individual German cities
were these people simply paper pushers
were they like Hannah Arendt the famous
philosopher depicted out of Eichmann in
a famous book Eichmann in Jerusalem
reporting the banality of evil for she
wrote after covering the trial in
Jerusalem District Court of Eichmann in
the early 1960s and published as a book
did she uh were these people as I said
simply but now all people who really
were no different from other Germans and
for no more responsibility really than
other Germans they were were they what
they said about them
simply people who are in a terrible
position and a difficult time and they
did their best given the situation that
they were in understanding these people
I think we can understand something
about the culpability and guilt of all
people involved in the Holocaust of the
Nazi crimes finally question which
people asked begin and again and I hope
I've added something to that debate
about the issue anyway is what did the
average Germans do and what did they
know about the Holocaust as it was
happening these are the major sets of
questions which I tried to deal with I'd
like to say that in studying this I
spent some six years living in Cologne
with my wife and eventually with our two
young sons both of our boys were born in
a hospital at the University of Cologne
I wouldn't have given birth along with
my wife to two boys if I was completely
uncomfortable in living in German
society and in fact I felt that I was
incredibly well treated in German
society and felt very much at home in
those years that I was there at first as
I was reading the case files of the
Gestapo and several communities that I
picked for my study they were the city
of Cologne a very large city of about a
million people a small relatively
unknown city of krei fell which has
about two hundred thousand residents and
a very small town which nobody probably
has ever heard of you listed from there
or from that area in Germany called Bank
I'm not too far from the Dutch and
Belgian border outside of Cologne had
about ten thousand residents the Third
Reich so I was studying a big city a
medium-sized city in a small town which
I thought would sort of canvass the
whole society in some ways but I can't
make claims for every single place in
Germany I studied these places and this
is what I know most about still I think
they have
in much the same way as other places
nevertheless as I was studying this at
first I found it fascinating even fun to
read Gestapo records they were Gustavo
Case Files and sometimes these Case
Files were about so thick and each one
seemed to be a kind of crime thriller at
first I didn't read about Jews by the
way at first I read about all the other
groups and I did a kind of random sample
of these Gestapo Case Files which were
available for me for these communities
so they read about 1,100 Gestapo Case
Files
each one took me about half a day to
read sometimes it would take me two days
some days I could read several in a day
but an average I could read about two in
a day I tried to keep detailed records
of each of these Case Files so I could
tell stories about them afterwards and
keep that sort of personal touch that
was involved cuz these were stories
about real human individuals and they're
not just to be forgotten about by being
glossed over by statistical evidence
although I tried to add them up too so
that I could give an analysis of the
situation so I was trying to produce an
analysis of these issues
and I scientific there was social
scientific level as well as to tell very
human stories and keep the human drama
that was very much there but first it
was you know as I say it was fascinating
to me and even fun as I read about
people like the Cologne priest Father
Joseph speaker I speak about in my book
at some length a man who gave a very
courageous sermon on Christ the King day
on October 28 1934 on the title of with
the title of true and false viewers and
he came out and started his his sermon
saying there is only one true Fuhrer
Christ the King now of course this is
something that Nazis didn't like very
much and there was a man sitting in the
audience who was a lower-level Nazi
Party functionary who was also a school
teacher he wrote down every thing that
father speaker said
immediately over the Gestapo
headquarters right after the trial I
mean sorry right after Father's because
my trial right after father speakers
sermon and so in this gut Father's beak
arrested and before long father speaker
was put on trial he was acquitted at
trial at first but the Ixtapa wasn't
happy with this so they arrested him on
the street on the court on the
courthouse steps as he walked out
supposedly a free man and so he became
the first Roman Catholic priest to go to
a concentration camp he's a completely
unheralded man but I found it somehow
uplifting even in a way to read about
father speaker as well as fascinating
didn't always find it uplifting to read
about these cases that I read but as it
went on and I eventually came to the
story of Jews and I saved them really
the Jewish situation for last I knew
which cake spouts I was going to read in
my study I wanted to see what everything
else was like before I actually went
into the persecution of the Jews and so
I spent several years reading the case
files of communist religious figures
like father speaker and just simply
ordinary Germans who might have been
denounced by a neighbor for saying
Hitler can lick my proverbial rear
anguish this often said back there and
got people in some trouble but usually
not much as long as they were just
average Germans originally sent home but
then the case files of the Jewish
Germans became more and more depressing
of course and by the end of nearly six
years I spend in Cologne as we left came
back to the United States just when I
started to write this book at Princeton
in summer of 1995
I found myself somewhere between
depressed and sick as I was involved in
not only reading Case Files then but
that time actually doing interviews with
men like this man I told you about just
as I started here today ended my book
with and began a little talk tonight
with this man who told me about waiting
in Jewish blood and how that was so
terrible for him that was actually the
last interview
I did so it was in the end a rather
difficult experience as writing the book
has been for me a rather difficult
experience I've written a couple of
other books before but never on such a
topic that touches so many people in
such a direct and personal way and I
found the enormous sense of
responsibility dealing with this subject
and I can never be sure that I'm done
the right thing I just done my level
best so I can say and doing it but I've
given it all the thought that I can over
the last four years as I've been writing
this book and finally brought it to
fruition now I've already told you
really about the kinds of evidence - of
the kinds of evidence that I used one
stopped all records and records of the
courts which dealt with political
offences during the Third Reich of which
I read a random sample of 1,100 cases
again W several years to do secondly I
carried out interviews with individual
victims bystanders and perpetrators
people who had experienced the Third
Reich at firsthand and often Nazi terror
sometimes were the victims of Nazi
terror like the many Jewish survivors
I've spoken with as well as sometimes
people who were directly perpetrators of
that terror like that man I talked about
with whom I was drinking in the morning
the other kind of evidence involved in
the study was I together with a German
sociologist who was an expert in opinion
research I went on and carried out pen
and pencil surveys with some about 7,000
people now from the cities that I
mentioned already and also some other
cities to see if they were
representative the places I studied of
all of Germany and so together with
colleagues Roy Cohn Reznick sociology at
the University of Dusseldorf we sent out
surveys to some 7,000 people randomly
select
that were born before 1928 on average
these people were about 25 or 27 at the
end of the Second World War so that they
were adults by the time the Third Reich
was over and they perceives and
experience the Third Reich as adults a
bit these surveys were things that we
didn't know if the Germans would ever
even respond to we had no idea something
like this hadn't been done before to my
knowledge and so I thought not to my
knowledge has it ever been done and
maybe it won't be possible to do it
again because these people are getting
old and large numbers of the people who
I surveyed actually I know I've died
already these people though were
remarkably willing to take part some of
them weren't so happy about taking part
and often sent back nasty letters to me
and saying why am i trying to ask these
nasty questions and why can't I just
like you know things lie as they are and
forget about all this
this can make their health bad and so on
but in nevertheless we sent out these
surveys and we also send them reminders
several times if they hadn't answered
they also carried out surveys with about
1,000 1,100 the Jewish Holocaust
survivors people were defined here
really as people who lived in Germany
who were Jewish during the period of the
Nazi Third Reich and were older than
children at some point at that time and
there of course the response was you
know enormous and I'm very thankful to
all the people with whom I'm spoken and
I'm sorry that I haven't gotten contact
with so many of them maybe some of them
are seeing me on television
with this talk right here tonight and I
I'm sorry if we're not getting back to
all of you I hope I can get back to more
of you over time I've just been writing
this book and only I finished it anyway
the final type of evidence that I had
was I tried to find out about the
backgrounds of these Gestapo officers
and I studied every single Gestapo
officer in the city of Craig fells which
only
about 25 Gestapo officers for the city
of 200,000 which should be revealing in
the first place because this was rather
average there was only about one Gestapo
officer for every 10,000 people in the
German population most scholars now read
on that figure and often there were no
Gestapo officers out in the countryside
but I wanted to know who were these
people were they all the same
were they ordinary were they just paper
stuffers these are what that is what
they said after the war so now I'll turn
to them if I win this is the one part up
sort of focus on a little bit more Mike
talk here tonight and I'll read just a
little bit about them so take just a few
minutes quickly I'll summarize about the
Gestapo officers I mean I read these but
these 25 people and Kray fell but I also
read about Gestapo officers in other
cities like crazy Pike Cologne and even
a few other places to see if the same
kinds of things applied as applied in
that city which I studied in most detail
this was it took me a long time to read
their records or even to get a hold of
them as a real big story usually because
you don't get your hands on the records
the case files of gestapo people
themselves and their interior ministry
files when they're trying to get their
pensions restored after the Third Reich
was over during the 1940s late 1940s and
1950s as I'm not even in the nineteen
sixties we're trying to escape
prosecution trying to be denied safai
dand so on getting a hold of these kinds
of records was quite a trick and I
received a lot of help from many German
archivists with without whose help I
could never have possibly done this
anyway these these Gestapo office like
dividing this three part the three
different groups summarize the first two
very quickly and just move to the third
the local Eichmann's the first two won't
surprise you very much the heads of the
Gestapo were people who were quite young
they remind me much of Reinhard Heydrich
who many of you may have heard of the
sort of the head of the whole terror
organization from Berlin a young man
cold very intelligent highly educated
and clearly an are did not see from the
big
they have some interesting stories and I
talked about Emanuel Schaffer from
Cologne to some length one of the
leaders of the Cologne Gestapo and
looked the Gillman the head of the club
Krefeld Gestapo yo meaning young in
Germany was deep very young he was only
28 years old Lee 1938 when he became
that of the crates out of gestapo and
remained there till 1945 but these men
called hardened very intelligent men
young as they were often with university
education sometimes in fact about half
of them with PhDs in law or don't come
is that much of a surprise to anybody I
don't think nor do the sort of flat feet
of the Gestapo they're regular cops the
sort of bad guys in the Gestapo who are
a little bit older on average or they
could be younger but they were typically
born sometime around 1900 on average and
some were born late or some were born
earlier but these people were not so
terribly highly educated they claimed
they were just regular German policeman
well I think they're much more than
German policeman these ones who would be
the Schlage or as the germans would call
them the people would be called upon to
beat on you if you needed to use beating
and force to care to get the information
to Gestapo wanted to get from somebody
these work harden pretty thuggish types
not stupid I had to be good enough to be
able to intelligent enough and schooled
enough to be able to write quite correct
German without a lot of mistakes in it
as they rode up their case files in
quite considerable lengths but again not
much surprised there the surprising ones
to me were the ones I called local
Eichmann's the people who headed the
Jewish deaths of the Gestapo in
individual German cities collar Fleur
and crepe and Cologne
Richard schulenburg in Krefeld are
examples what was really astounding to
me was that when I finally got a hold of
their case files and started reading
about them I started reading letter upon
letter from leading figures from their
communities
after the war who wrote these glowing
letters saying how these men were the
real exceptions they were the one good
person in the Gestapo there they were
out helping Jews not trying to kill Jews
but the letters can't I mean it seems
impossible but when the when I read
letters that came from the head of the
Protestant Church of crave felt and also
from Cologne and head of the Catholic
Church
except for okay fellow not the
archbishop at the man right below him in
provincial own from leaders in German
politics after the war from leaders in
the business life of the nation and even
from some Jewish survivors who were
still living there I started to wonder
can it be could it possibly be and this
was a question that's hunts haunted me
for a long time and still wants me some
today is this still a slight nagging
doubt in my mind but if you read the
book you'll find out that I argued that
no I don't think these people were the
men that they presented themselves to be
they were surprisingly quite old Richard
Schulenburg was born in 1879 so that
when he was sending Jews off to their
death in 1942 he was 63 years old uh
caller four of Cologne was a bit younger
he's born in 1888 but he was still in
his late 50s when he was doing this
these are men that Jewish survivors with
whom I've talked met them personally
have told me they were actually quite
friendly types they didn't use the due
form and addressing them the Jews which
is to put down in German as I'm sure
many of you know it's used for usually
for children for animals they use Z the
polite way of talking with them one
woman told me she said I just died
schulenburg he was kind of jovial when I
talked
the kind of yo viale smiled at me I can
imagine him sitting at the stump tissue
decision she said you know sitting at
that regular pub with his cronies well
he was at the stump test a lot that's
why he had so many people would support
him after the war and what I want to
argue though is that this was a kind of
cynical policy on the part of the
Gestapo I don't have a letter that
proves this but I seem these people like
these people in the five different
communities looked at and will looked at
five and there seems to be the same
kinds of people the same style they
didn't wear an SS uniform they weren't
members of the SS they were friendly
with the local communities they seemed
to be friendly even when they dealt with
the Jews of course they could
immediately turn to their ally they're
there the other sort of rank-and-file
guys and used more forceful tactics if
that was necessary but they prefer to do
things quietly peacefully keep all sides
quiet was I think what their motto was
but I thought I'd just read a quick
statement that was given by one of the
people who wrote one of these glowing
letters for Richard schulenburg and
February of 1947 as he was going through
his denazification hearings with the
British authorities this was a doctor
from Berlin the head of the cradle
Catholic Church he said mr. Schoenberg
was head criminal secretary in the
political section of the police force
when the police force was nationalized
it was compulsory for him to remain with
the State Police hearing was exceedingly
humane and Justin carrying out his
duties as an almost permanent guest of
the Gestapo I heard this repeatedly from
various sides I was told the same
especially by many persecuted Jews who
came to me in great numbers as I was
entrusted with the care of a Jewish
religious relics schulenburg was in
charge of the Jewish Department and as
Jews told me he always treated them
decently and as far as he was able
offered them many possibilities and he
injustice hardness and ill treatment was
incompatible with a decency of his
character I'm glad to be
to issue this evidence for a gentleman
who belongs to the Protestant community
then I might read from what cobbler
floor is parallel cologne said about
himself a year later as he was going
through his denunciation hearings which
it works very similar to what mr.
Schoenberg also used in other people who
are these local Whiteman's used after
the war I always hated the work I had to
do in the political arena
I tried therefore from the beginning to
compensate for it especially when the
heart beat too heavily measures that
were ordered to be taken against those
did not hold to Nazi vote views in most
cases I did not carry out or I made up
my reports in such a way that the people
were left untouched over time I tried
again and again in vain to be sent back
to the political police even though I
was not successful in that attempt I
nevertheless have the satisfaction today
that through my passive behavior many
people had an easier fate indeed in many
cases lives were saved I also tried to
escape from my office through repeated
sick leaves the last of 1942 when I
spent almost eight weeks under a
doctor's care despite this I was
commanded to go to Brussels where I
believe he went on and carried out the
same kind of activities and we didn't
say that
after the Nazis take over power the Jews
over the years became more and more
constricted by National Socialism and
their rights and their freedom of
movement he said in another place in the
end the Jews were forcibly deported by
the Koch estoppel to the east as I have
heard from the district of Cologne they
were sent to lists munch dot loads what
happened with the Jews after this is
outside my knowledge I came to know
about that only after the end of the war
well I want to leave time for questions
and so I'm not going to read a passage
which is a little bit longer one that I
thought I might do but that was one
piece of I'm so summarized it quickly of
counter-evidence
about these people which came after the
war from a couple known as the libertine
couple of Cologne mr. Levenstein for a
short time right after the war
the head of the Jewish community in
Cologne and he was married to a Catholic
woman Regina liver Stein their son was
thus according to Nazi parlance a
Michelin a half Jew was another way of
describing them the michelin is probably
most of you know or the half Jews people
would one non-jewish parent were the
most likely people of Jewish background
at all to survive during the Holocaust
along with people who were married to
non-jews and so he may have survived
argued the leverage signs which he
didn't after was sent by mr. Baer for to
Auschwitz in the summer of 1942 he may
have survived he didn't have to be sent
to Auschwitz but according to their
testimony according to some others who
actually even sat in the cell with their
saw in the 26 year old young man mr.
Lafleur on purpose when after their son
and used the very dubious German laws
against them even in the legal fashion
they said that he didn't wear his Jewish
star when in fact the Michelin they
argued didn't have to wear a Jewish star
and it gets to be a very technical and
convoluted kind of argument but the
importance of it is upshot of it all is
is that they argue very strongly and I
would argue it too that these
individuals estoppel people had
individual decision-making capability
and they made decisions they could have
chosen to let people live and they often
chose to have people die
I fight the words of Simon Wiesenthal a
little epigram to the last section of
the book in one place he said after the
war I heard about so many Gestapo
officers and Hood save Jews it was
surprised that there weren't more Jews
alive at the end of the war than there
were you know at the beginning of it the
man who has the power to save also has
the power to condemn so in some another
summarizing some questions if anybody
has any I argued that these Gestapo
officers even these those are nice guys
these local Eichmann's are people who
are not nice guys and in my mind we have
to hold them accountable for their deeds
at least in historical memory and I
think we also need to distinguish a sum
between these people in the average
Germans and the population now I spent
rather more than half of my study with
the ordinary Germans the non-jewish
Germans and what I come up with is not a
terribly flattering picture of them
either I argued quite strongly in the
next the last chapter of my book that a
large plurality perhaps even a majority
of the German population became quite
aware well before the end of the war
that Jews were being murdered in the
mass they heard this from BBC broadcasts
they heard this from people coming back
from the front
some of them participated in at the mem
cells in a direct way they heard about
it from many different ways and they've
told me that they told me that in their
surveys I did with them they told me
that in interviews that I did with them
personally and has recorded on tape
but even though they knew this and
didn't do anything which is not
something which is to be wanted to be
sure and even if at times they did some
other things and many of them did this
is not to say that they were all ardent
anti-semites it's not to say that they
desired to see the Jews killed or to
perpetrate awful acts as the person who
wrote a perceptive review of my book in
The New York Times a couple of weeks ago
rogue or uses a sort of title of his
review you know these people who were
Hitler's silent partners in a way and he
said about me and I think he's probably
right I mean I'm very gyu and I don't
know him at all an editor for The Times
he said that perhaps the most damning
thing that Johnson says is that ordinary
Germans may not even have realized until
very late in the war if at all
that they were living in a very vile
dictatorship and so it's not a very
commendable thing that more not much I
can do to commend the German population
in a general way but I think we really
have to remember that there's a
difference between the people who
organized and led the perpetration of
Nazi crimes in the Holocaust and the
normal German population out there I
don't think we should just paint them
with one brush when I talked to the
survivors of the city of Krefeld a small
community which today numbers far less
than 100 but I did have successful a
survey with them and they answered in
great numbers and they were very willing
to talk about this and as I heard from
many many other survivors
Jews who lived through that time to have
very different views amongst themselves
about the issue of anti-semitism in
Germany and how they were treated by
their German classmates new German
neighbors and the people from their
towns some say and I've heard the only
good German you know his proverbial dead
German we should make you know the city
I came from remember one men same
Dresden into some kind of a park and
used the Jews for the Germans for food
the Germans for fear of fertilizer is
tremendous anger of course many people
but then I heard for many many others
that they were treated very humanely and
very decently in surveys about 10
percent of them told me this is Jewish
were Holocaust survivors again told me
that they receive significant help from
their turban neighbors and often and
helped save their lives and so I think
we need to see this very difficult
situation and more than just black and
white terms even though black and white
kind of terms are comfortable and we can
say this is what happened I think it's
much more complicated than that it's
probably but at that thank you
[Applause]
yes sir
motivated did you feel indeed that the
Germans have been painted with the
single brush and so that in part you
wanted to and that you felt things were
more complicated than that I'm wondering
a little bit about no I don't that would
be saying that I knew more about things
than I really did to be sure when I
started out doing this I try to address
this a little bit in that practice which
I grow up in one day sitting in a garage
of our farm summer home in the coast of
Maine after I'd already written the book
I tried to write something that wouldn't
embarrass me too much but it actually
came from the heart I don't really know
why I undertake these things and I you
know create reasons but there's a
professional and a kind of personal
reason the professional reason is simple
enough and that is that I had written a
couple of books about policing and
violence and crime and German history in
the nineteenth century and I was very
curious to see if there was any
continuity with the period of the Third
Reich and so I could easily convince her
persuade grant-giving
organizations who would finance my
studies in Germany who support me and I
was very lucky to receive the support of
several foundations
like the National Science Foundation
National Endowment humanities and the
Fulbright Foundation as well as the
German foundation called the Alexander
von Humboldt Foundation so I had support
and I couldn't have done it without
support so I had to live on something
but the personal reason is a little bit
more difficult to assess but I could say
and I do say in my book so it's out
there for anybody to see that my father
was an American pilot during the second
war he was stationed Bari Italy he was
shut down in the fall of 1944 just south
of Salzburg and a small town not far
from Hitler's Eagle's Nest if you ever
went there I was astounded I went there
for the first time in May of 1995 to
look up in the hands of my god I'm just
on the other side of if it was Eagle's
Nest I'd been there from the German side
before it over Salzburg but never from
the Austrian side I know more about
Germany and in Austria
my father's no dad he died in 1991 he
survived but this was a very painful
experience for him and he didn't feel
like the hero I guess that he wanted to
feel like being an American pilot he
felt that somehow he did wrong his plane
was shot down he wasn't good enough
eyelet he didn't commit us he didn't
finish his mission correctly I don't
know what that was exactly maybe he
talked too much
in fact that's my own suspicion that
maybe he said more than name rank and
serial number
and I really wanted to know what was it
like to be in a Gestapo interrogation
I've always sort of had bad dreams about
such things and so it sort of haunted me
so it's not exactly my father's story
it's a different story but I wanted to
be inside of that Nazi Germany for some
period to understand what it was like
for my father and then of course for so
many other people who suffered so much
more than my father well now I think I
know
yes sir how does your book differ
basically from gold Hagen's didn't he
come to some similar conclusions about
good and bad Nazis about righties
diluting the possession the thievery and
so on
well I'm often asked that question it's
kind of an embarrassing day I like to
say that you know I wrote a review of
the Nouvelle Vague ins book which was
not as condemnatory as some of my
colleagues did he received great support
from many many people and often many
Germans in fact but amongst the academic
community received quite a rough ride at
times and I've even personally observed
it a little bit not really taking part
in it but I felt for Daniel Goldhagen
some because it was tough to be
criticized as savagely as he's been by
stomach and I wrote a review in
Germany's Journal distortion sytrus this
just means a historical journal which
wasn't a too terribly important one
maybe but maybe it was a little bit less
possible than some others so I think
you're quite right in positioning my
statements as something there is not a
total condemnation of Daniel Goldhagen
'zv use however I think where I differs
disagree with mr. Goldhagen is in
particular on the motivations for
average Germans or ordinary Germans to
take part in Nazi crimes in the
Holocaust I don't disagree with him that
Nazis made ordinary Germans did indeed
take part in perpetrating Nazi crimes
thank so much evidence to support this
of a slightly different type as he
focuses on the killing of Jews in
particular in the east or is like focus
on the entire terror for all people
inside of Germany itself but I think
where I disagree mostly what mr. Gould
Hagen has to do with his argument about
why this happened and whereas he argues
quite strongly that it happened because
there was a
of all pervasive what he calls
elimination is anti-semitism that had
been in German culture for quite a long
time who simply unleashed by olive
Hitler and that led Germans to be very
willing to take part in the murder of
Jews I give evidence like I've talked
about a little bit here tonight like
from the survey of crave thought
survivors and other Germans of Jewish
survivors who say that they did nothing
selves not perceive so much
anti-semitism they didn't receive that
much that there was a big there was
abroad but there was a serious
differences it was very nuanced there's
different views that different people
had some Jews received where the you
know experienced terrible anti-semitism
others did not and so I don't think it's
so simple as that and furthermore many
other groups - I don't want to get into
comparing things between one group and
another who suffered the most because
everybody who suffers suffers terribly
but we need to be reminded that
something like a hundred thousand people
who are mentally and physically
deficient or put to death and they were
often ordinary Germans if you will not
Jewish German some of them were Jews -
before the Jews were put to death on
mass in Germany more than that thousands
of gypsies were also killed and millions
of Russians and poles ultimately and so
I don't know if it's the Germans
motivation was because they wanted to
kill Jews specifically they showed
themselves to be quite willing and very
capable at killing many types of people
so I suppose that my difference with mr.
gold Hagen has to do with the
motivations of the ordinary Germans to
take part
yes sir down here god Hagen's book
actually the subtitle of cold Hagen's
book is to ordinary Germans with the
hardcore but in this book the bulk of
his book doesn't deal with ordinary
Germans
very little now hardly at all but only
with police units which are trusted to
become exterminators in Poland and in
Russia so actually he he that's what he
makes it main point factually not about
ordinary Germans what he returned as you
say he just goes back into the past and
I went salted there has always been
anti-semitism in German and so on but
his sexual proving points deal only with
police units who were drafted into the
to become exterminate well this is one
of the points of criticism of Daniel
Goldhagen spoke but I think Daniel
Goldhagen I don't know what I wanted
defend then to go big in an argued into
gold egg is line but I think in his
defense I could say that he would argue
and other people have written about this
like Christopher browning who wrote
about a first and a very powerful book
and he should be remembered here we're
going to talk about Daniel Goldhagen we
should give a good press to Christopher
browning because his book you know
ordinary man in the title of it
originally talked about these police
battalions first and both of them
demonstrate that they have some
differences between them that these
police battalions were made up often of
people who were by training not police
officers but who were rather kind of
reserved police officers more or less
like reservists in the National Guard in
the United States that would take it to
be were called up periodically they
didn't know what they were to do at
first but then they were told they were
to kill Jews but these people could be
players in the Hamburg Orchestra like
they were studying Hamburg in particular
they could be people
who were ditch figures they could be
teachers they could be people from all
different walks of life and they were
and so they were quite ordinary
individuals who joined up in these
police battalions I believe both of them
argue more or less like ordinary
Americans during the Vietnam War were
members of the National Guard you might
also say also members of the army food
but so I think it's they would argue
it's not simply police men but they were
these reservists so they came from all
different parts of the copy of the
population worth mentioning of Goldhagen
book is that he points out that each
police units were permitted to refuse
service to refuse kill and very few of
you did availed themselves of a they are
not punished Toit right I mean both both
he and and Christopher browning make
exactly that point that the people were
told that they had the right to refuse
and nothing would happen to them and
there's no known case of anybody who did
refuse who had anything bad happened to
them though some people did refuse to do
this I can say that I'm not sure this is
the way it happened all the time I
remember interviewing one man who took
who was given the task he was in the
German army in an artillery unit he was
a lieutenant and it was his job to
organize a group of people who would
isolate perform a salats yawns commando
kind of isolate the town was down along
the Black Sea I forget exactly the town
haven't gone back and written about this
case actually I'm gonna doing the
subsequent book but and he was to get 20
men to seal off the town so that the
townspeople wouldn't be able to go out
to where the shooting would be done of
thousands of Jews and I asked him I said
how did you get these 20 men he said oh
that was no trouble at all I just asked
for volunteers and my hands went up so
there were a variety of ways I think of
recruiting people to get them take part
yes sir
seems that everybody forgets about the
booklet by Lucy Davila which number of
years ago called war against the Jews
where she showed she stipulated that the
Holocaust was a perfectly normal
reaction to what had been going on in
Eastern Europe and Germany especially
from the 16th and 1700s and the
progression and she very carefully shows
the progression from that period of time
of the anti-semitism going on in that
area right up until and including the
Holocaust
you never hear that's spoken about
anymore
well I don't know I'm not some people
who all two views that that may be
similar to Daniel Goldhagen way might be
put in that camp a little bit even if
lucida visits is not being talked about
as much now in her book which is you
know still a valuable book but now has a
few decades on it and she's dead now and
so perhaps because she's not there
people are not talking about it as much
but I do believe that the most of the
people who study these issues now as I
would say most I think do not really
quite agree that the history of
anti-semitism in German lands anyway is
so unique and in that Germany is so
greatly different from other places you
mentioned I think just Poland right then
I mean that Germany is really any
different than Nepal I think what is so
surprising in some ways about
word the so odd in some ways is that
Jews would feel in Germany anyway highly
integrated into that society in 1933
over a third of the marriages of Jews
will with non-jews at that time and I
don't think it's because they were just
simply trying to get a better deal
somehow because that's what they fell in
love with and they felt themselves to be
as much German as American Jewry feels
itself to be American and probably I
don't know how I would you know I can't
ask those people exactly but my guess is
some large large numbers of them would
hardly have even perceived in themselves
as Jews at all they weren't necessarily
religious they had fought in the First
World War they had been decorated for
bravery I see again and again in the
records people who are proud of their
iron crosses I talk about one man 94
years old he was deported from crazy
self train station and he walked there
with his iron cross next to his Jewish
star on his chest or they felt very
proud to be Germans so I don't want to
criticize lucida bit of it but I think
my own views would not go along with
some of the things that I think she
argued but I'd have to review her book
again honestly it's not as present in my
mind just some others and thank you for
reminding me about it I probably should
go back and look at it yes the daughter
survivors and my grandmother went back
to Berlin after the war so I spent quite
a lot of years going back to visitor I
think a very important element in the
German character is their absolute
obedience
two things they're not there's something
in the mentality certainly my mother
they don't that's a question not to go
against orders if you're told to do
something you do it
there's not like in this country a
questioning a rebelling go this is it
and I think that's also what helped
perpetrate a lot of the crimes well I
think so absolutely it's hard to prove
this and it starts to get into sort of
almost stereotypical talk which we
usually want to refrain from but Germans
recognized today that it's important to
cultivate individualism and German
society and you hear them talk
frequently about Sevilla rajma that
individual Germans are to have the
courage to stand up against the
authority when they see it as being
wrong and you know if you've spent any
time in Germany you will notice how you
know people don't walk across the street
unless the light you know turns green
and even on Sunday mornings when
nobody's in the street or something like
that
and I've had my friends remember Henning
Cowen and his son David he's a good
friend of mine having to visit me and I
think now daddy was professor of
American literature at the University of
Pennsylvania and David was my friend
when I was a graduate student there and
we were there this is just 1994 I
believe and it was a Sunday morning and
we were walking just in our career the
quiet part of the town and I was
standing there waiting in a corner and
there was nobody there
and there was a light there's no cars
coming from any direction you couldn't
hear any cars been doing they said come
on let's walk across the street what's
the matter with you you can come German
or something there I said well you just
don't do it once you've been here for a
while you never know there could be a
grandmother over there who's gonna look
at you and when the finger at him just a
little bit you said that grandmother one
time that's enough to stop you in your
tracks you know you feel like you're
just some kind of criminal yourself and
so you start to conform and you start to
go along certainly German society has
you know a great reputation perhaps
reason deserved for being quite obedient
people
and by my studies of German law and
policing in the 19th century this was
quite evident to me as well that this is
society which holds individual activity
as somewhat strange although today they
are trying to cultivate it but I also
want to say as part of my background is
also Swedish in Sweden I can remember as
a student being there that back in 1970
when I was a student diversity of
thought Hall might stand out there at
the light and I swear people would wait
there for two days without going across
the street if the man didn't turn green
as well and no sweets I've been held
I don't think so for perpetrating the
Holocaust they have a different
reputation so it's difficult question
but stuff there is something there what
you're saying which is significant yes
sir
some of the questions actually you
answered already I just have a comment
I didn't read you a book and of course
what you're talking a little excerpt of
your book about those so they stopped
the officer who may have been a
wonderful benign gentleman I'm just
wondering how many Jews has he has he
saved in Krefeld and why having so few
Jews being saved if there was some Nazi
officers or rather his top officers work
so be nice but the not see that Gestapo
officer is really not that important you
probably have that in the book but you
didn't mention there were a lot of
helpers who assisted the Gestapo the SR
the SS etc some civilians who the
confidants these are the typical methods
of totalitarian regimes be it fascist or
communist well I have one final comment
I wonder whether you've had time to
include in that book the memoirs of
Marcel right REM Itsuki the German
fellow he is a German Polish right are
very famous in German
and he was educated in Germany as a Jew
and he sat next to a guy who was very
friendly with him
they went to coffee and soccer games
together the guy next to him knew that
ramit ski was a Jew but then he his
so-called friend put on his brown shirt
and went to up to hit the Jews so that
some of those guys may have been
friendly doesn't mean anything yeah well
I think you say better than I can
probably oh I what you're just talking
about this man the last man you talked
about one of the men who I interviewed
in the book is the man who was still
living in Colin if he's still alive I
haven't spoken with him in three years
and he survived Auschwitz he's about 80
years old now if he's still alive and he
talked about how he played in the swing
group and he was a musician he later
became an architect but music was his
passion and especially swing music which
was forbidden music at the time and he
played with the son of a Gestapo officer
but you say it didn't mean anything
maybe he survived because he was the
friend of the son of the Gestapo officer
on the other hand maybe he was sent off
because he was the son of the Gestapo
officer because he was his mother was
Catholic and his father was Jewish and
being a mixed background he didn't
necessarily go I don't know for certain
in his case it's very difficult it may
mean something and it may not certainly
the first point that you raised about
Gestapo officers who may have been acted
benign you know how many did they save I
don't think they save to anybody at all
except for maybe one or two people who
were there sort of special friends of
somehow or somebody they had special
pity for violence these people as as
people who had pity at all I think it
was a terrible cynical activity that
they carried on and dodged that they
were pretending to care and elite they
cared a bit that's the argument that I
made yeah if you believed as I do that
the killings that happened in the
Holocaust and the papers in the papers
that we read today in the Herald and New
York Times and so forth were simply
optical illusions that exist like I
don't know what gargoyles would be in
front of a church to prepare a young
lover or a young man to cleanse his
heart before he entered and met his his
bride or something of that sort that
these things existed like whales of your
with teeth and so on that scared the
first the first travelers to the new
world and so on that prevented you from
making a contact with the one you love
that these things were toothy spirits
that that couldn't necessarily touch you
that if you had an open heart and we're
in love that they would fall like like
paper I
I think they can't really grasp what
you're saying I've haven't heard some
terribly intelligent sort of postmodern
someplace but I've been much more
empirically minded sort of than all of
this is so I'm not I'm not really
grasping it I mean are you trying to ask
me and do I think in some way that this
stuff didn't happen or that it happened
but that it's I guess it's an abortion
somehow or it's not supposed to scare
you that they're supposed to make you
fall in love maybe kiss a Nazi you know
I had anyway I had as I started out with
many buzzing Nazis it's incredibly how
nice the Nazis can be even today you go
into no ingratiating they are you go to
their place they serve you wine they
tell you that your grandmother your
mother-in-law who's an English woman my
mother and her father who was an
American intelligence officer and Berlin
after the Warren was the American army
the intelligence and now how when they
were gonna come they should go over
their house and they could stay there
because they we probably couldn't afford
to put in such a nice hotel as they live
in these nice places the first time I
met these people is he's a big
businessman his wife you know was the an
old wooden bunch of NATO field and that
means a the head of a sort of german
girls league under the Nazis and you
know they were also very very nice why
they could be incredibly nice but I
didn't ever want to kiss any of them
and after seeing the book he will be
funny right afterward
thank you very much
[Applause]